from foreign policy.com blinken
authorizes u.s embassies worldwide to
display blm flags
a new directive comes while the united
states commemorates the anniversary of
george floyd's murder they say blinken
has announced the u.s secretary of state
u.s embassies around the world to fly
the blm flags and banners according to
an internal cable reviewed by foreign
policy as part of the administration's
response to the one-year anniversary of
the killing of george floyd the state
state department cable gives chiefs of
missions who had us embassies and
consulates worldwide blanket written
authorization to display blm flags and
banners as appropriate in light of local
conditions
there you go
they're going to be flying
the black lives matter flag and our
embassies and conflict this is the fist
the the
power fists could be they want to the
marxist organization hell bent on
destroying the united states we are
going to fly their flag who won
who won
let me show you something let me show
you some images so here we have black
lives matter and you can see the raised
fist the red salute see another flag
with the red salute there's the red
salute and a lot of people say oh tim
here's here's some black lives matter
red salute red salute and people say oh
it's it just means black power
and i'm like yeah and then nazi salute
means white power i don't care what you
think it means when the chinese
communist party swear in a party member
they they raise their fist in the red
salute
they still do
and so a lot of people don't seem to
understand that
it is the anti-fascist salute just like
the berlin wall was the anti-fascist
protection rampart it is called that's
what it was called it's the red salute
and just because other groups have
peripheral support for uh communist
ideology does not change what that
symbol means like we mentioned this
often but it's it's ancient hinduism the
swastika it was inverted i don't care
it's a it's a nazi symbol that's there
you go
symbols can be taken over and they can
represent bad things you're not going to
come to me and raise your your red
salute to to communist authoritarianism
and have me be like oh did you mean
something else
so now think about this
american embassies and consulates will
be flying symbols of communism well they
can right that's what this says they're
encouraging them blanket authorization
to fly the flag
so yes when they raise the flag blanket
authorization saying if you want to show
your fealty you better step up and do it
it's optional of course
optional if you don't do it then you
might as well be that guy that got fired
from space force for saying that marxism
is taking over
the military yeah i don't know where
this goes other than that it's
terrifying i am i'm a little bit more
upset tonight than usual because i just
keep thinking about i read the text okay
the text says disrupt the nuclear family
disrupt the capitalism society destruct
just deconstruct and disrupt american
culture it's in the freaking literature
and we're gonna fly their flag yep what
if who why isn't anybody reading
anything these are the people who say
that america is evil as a slaveocracy
that you know whiteness is inherently
bad that being on time is bad and we're
flying their flags i'm reading their
books
saying their words and being told that
i'm the crazy one and i'm making it up
while they're flying the
gdblm flag over our government
properties yep yeah
that's reality
and i it just
jack exploded i just exploded
sometimes i've just had enough i think
i'm a little emotional because of this
medical procedure thing that people are
doing right now and the pressures i
think it's just the heat in the room
and the tension in the drama and the
peer pressure and the coercion and the
lies and the misinformation and the lack
of effort and the lack of agency and the
lack of personal accountability
and just pushing that all off on
everybody the whole thing is about
pushing it all off on everybody we got
to pop this zit you know when you
squeeze a zit and it hurts this this
this critical theory thing is like a
painful zit where you squeeze it and it
hurts and it's sore because nothing's
coming out but if you get it just right
it stings and it explodes and then no
it's normal it's wishful thinking but
too many people are cowards
too many and they're pushing them the
wrong way they're pushing and they're
bruising it and they're breaking blood
vessels because they're not getting the
stuff out
most people are
are cowards yeah that's true republican
party especially it's comprised of like
85 percent cowards i mean whatever they
look dude nancy pelosi comes out and
kevin mccarthy drops to his feet and
licks her drops to his knees and licks
her feet yeah and then ilhan omar comes
out and says a whole bunch of you know
ridiculous nonsense and pelosi is like
she's fine it's fine i mean the gop
establishment itself especially so i'm
not here to criticize everybody in
america but the truth is is that like
common people again
it's about where do you put where do you
put your energy and in the past
it was made more sense to focus more on
things that might be a little bit more
in front of your face but today it makes
sense to pay attention to things that
are a little bit bigger picture because
your family is at risk your family is at
risk this is not about different
marginal tax rates this is not about
tariffs it's not about contributions to
foreign alliances or even oil
it's about the very fundamental nature
of who we are as a country our
definitions of justice our system of of
of applying prestige and and and and and
resources
it's it's coming apart and people aren't
attention and no one believes it and
it's also for a large portion of this
country a question of your immortal soul
which is one of the bigger issues that i
find interesting is that you know
christians are particularly inactive as
well and many churches are flying blm
flags too like in dc totally so they're
adopting a moral framework which uh
eschews judeo-christian values
completely
yes i've heard i am not a churchgoer but
i have heard often
uh stories that the church has become
woke yeah well not all of them but i
know but about a lot in in a way in that
the institution isn't really a reliable
defender of the things that we're
interested in
no the church is not the catholic church
is a business
and it's a business that functions off
of control that's not and they're
seating control that's that's kind of
the point
yeah i feel like these these are they're
giving up their own moral tenants to a a
moral-less framework
christianity is wonderful it has a lot
of wonderful tenets but the church
itself is a dangerous business and
there's a much bigger church that
they're bowing bowing to so what do you
think happens when they give all their
power to an even worse and evil evil
institution at the very least
these churches gave us you know as i
often said blackstone's formulation but
the moral framework of wokeness is
sacrifice for power so you could be a
good woke fearing ideologue and they
will sacrifice you in a moment's notice
for power
look at that that woman on the board of
the schools in san francisco sacramento
or whatever she was ragging on asians
all day and night why because they said
to because i said asians were white
adjacent to dead power and privilege
then they realized there was power to be
made with the stop asian hate movement
so they threw her under the bus
immediately and she fought and she
resisted and they canceled her
because she's a bigot i want to point
out and call out some people some shout
outs though these guys in loudoun county
are really fighting for oh yeah that's
not too far from me they're really
fighting for it um there's people good
skatepark there who are really ian pryor
is leading a team of parents and they're
really working hard to fight back
against this they understand they're
woke and you know what these people in
loudoun county that are fighting this
they follow me they follow you they're
listening to us good what are they doing
they're they're trying to recall the
school board they're trying to get rid
of all the woke stuff out of their
curriculum they're trying to parents
right their parents they're trying to
keep like advanced mathematics and
things like that they're fighting back
so these these are not the people i
refer to when i say most people are
cowards no i know this is the opposite
i'm saying i want to shout these people
out i want to give them the recognition
that they deserve and i want other
people to see
acts of courage that is an act of
courage what's happening in loudoun
county
follow these people
do what they're doing use them as
inspiration and honestly we have to keep
doing what we're doing these people
literally follow us they literally read
what we're saying they listen to our
videos they take it home and they're
putting it into action kudos to you and
to everyone else who's doing i think we
both clearly like talking so i think
we're good we'll keep doing it
i'm having i'm having mixed emotions
about it because i'm talking i didn't
drink any coffee so i'm not stemmed
right now oh and you don't have that
that that biotrust the power i don't get
the biotrust
thanks if i was stemmed up right now i
would just be drenched i'd be in a pool
of water it's like 85 so the power
because it just hopped in like the power
for those that just popped in
the power's been out for a while we
might get cut off at any moment because
we're running on multiple bad like
multiple battery backups because we're
smart you know over here at tim castle i
just don't know what to say about this
like i'm trying to picture a situation
where this we get this outer layer of
crusty crap that schluffs off like the
the critical crap that just eventually
would just falls away in the united
states is there again but
i can't imagine that making it get worse
it's never going to make it get better
it's never been perfect it's always the
fight that we are having
has always existed civil rights the
civil rights movement was a fight for
individual liberties and you know
anti-discrimination and a lot of these
things were opposing ideology so
america's never been perfect but the
framework has been the best we've seen
right in history it enables us to do
shows and so and and we've we've built
we've built up over hundreds of years
we've been getting better and better and
better we've had some bad moments i
think everybody really hates woodrow
wilson i think michael malus for the
most part he was like that's that's what
he said worst president of all time mega
fascists signed the fact that yeah yeah
federal reserve stuff so so there's
there's some there's we've been
exploited but right now
illiberal ideologues once again moral
authoritarians are trying to seize power
and the and the true individualists the
true classical liberals those who
believe in life liberty and the pursuit
of happiness have to keep fighting
because authoritarians always want to
steal power it was dave smith said that
but i think mike mouse said that fdr was
the is the worst president of all time
which i was no no michael mouse was
talking about world war one wild woodrow
wilson high school was my local high
school in washington dc they're going to
change the name to ruth bader ginsburg
high school
he wasn't the greatest yeah i i actually
like that you know do you like that name
actually woodrow wilson seems like a
pretty bad dude he's in the federal
reserve act yeah yeah yeah ruth bader
that's probably a better trade i don't
agree with her on her rulings but you
know woodrow olson seems pretty bad
federal reserve not a good thing not a
good thing so and the fed
is this partly because the government
was co-opted in the early 1900s by the
rockefellers i don't know but if you
think about it like this if you give
everybody a voice and there's enough
voices saying the wrong thing then they
can make the wrong thing be what's
happening in the whole country and
that's what we're getting right now so i
wonder about the power of that it's time
to start beginning post-liberal
exploring post-liberal options
what do you mean by that post post
whatever we got going on right now so
you think this is the democratization of
communication has enabled bad
communication the democratization of
communication has destroyed public
residence
we used to all resonate together mostly
because we were on the same narrative
and that same narrative came from just a
handful of people walter cronkite or
whoever owned a handful of newspapers or
whatever the case may be jimi hendrix
explosion of communication from the many
to the many and now we are no longer in
residence and we will never be back in
residence ever again in the way that we
used to so you know what we really need
is maybe like uh
if you're if a bunch of people are
watching say a political show it's live
and they're and this is what we need to
hear more of they should share the link
they should take the link and smash the
like button
and then take the link to that show and
share with everybody so that we all get
on the same page start learning about
what's going on and uh then look
productive that is not just a cold
shameless plug
smash that like button sure it is but
i just got dms right now from a parent
in loudon watching us right now saying
i'm watching you from loudon thanks for
shouting us out
if you share this show and share our
content more people will find out and
more people will step up it's not
a uh galactic size exaggeration to say
that you can help save the fate of this
country by by sharing the show well well
i'm it's it's like that no you could do
it fast too think think about it this
way
have you ever have you ever have you
ever gone into private mode on youtube
and then like have you ever gone like a
private tab and then opened youtube sure
and what do you see
not me no you see a bunch of weird like
weird corporate youtube nonsense and
mainstream
so regular people aren't seeing any of
this and if people don't know how can
they stand up to it how can they
understand why it's bad so that means if
you do know
just click share i'm not telling you go
preach on a street corner holding up a a
i'm a gorilla t-shirt being like you
must watch
tim can you should be like hey guys
check out the show let me know if you
like it just send it to three or three
friends
i mean look and buy and buy books
because then they appear on the top of
the the amazon list for regular people
so you've had andy nosebook on antifa
which is really important for the people
who don't know antifa exists you can get
his book you've got michael malus he's
got a new book and speechless by michael
knowles available for pre-order
uh james o'keefe has several books
american pravda democrats are deplorable
that's also a good one by one i don't
know about that one i was not so bad not
so bad democrat
i'm not trying to tout my show too hard
but i do consistently get people saying
look this show's woefully unsubscribed
and underviewed and i know for a fact
we're having the just like here just top
level conversations with high level
government officials philosophers
activists academics etc cetera you got
to share it we got to share it because
we literally are all in this together
we'll all have a part to play think
about it this way the uh
religious
say you have to preach it seem like a
core tenant of many religions to preach
and spread the word and the woke not
only do they preach and spread the word
they threaten violence against those who
reject it
so think about what we're up against
we're saying life liberty to the pursuit
of happiness objectivity work hard plan
for the future they say those things are
bad we're seeing the consulate fly the
flag of black lives matter
if you take issue with these things and
you believe no no no no no no no no no
if you believe that two plus two does
not equal five
then you need to start talking about
this because they are teaching your kids
your your your nieces your nephews
they're teaching them that two plus two
equals five i'm not it's not an
exaggeration they're literally doing it
they're saying they're saying math is a
construct of whiteness science and
objectivity are a construct of whiteness
i watched a video i don't know if you
could remember this one jack where there
was a science class and there was a woke
person saying that the the ancient
african knowledge was spiritual
awareness and it's equally as plausible
as the scientific method and people were
like oh wow you know interesting and
it's like dude
there are a lot of hidden truths that
have been ignored and rejected that i
can accept there's like we talked about
the ant hills where they funnel heat out
of the ant colony and then you know
tribes in africa figured that out and
they could build
you know houses that were cooler
so there's a lot of things we have lost
but that doesn't mean the scientific
method a framework of control and
discovery is whiteness
it's just like math two plus two equals
four you can change the definition of
the words you can say flub plus flub
equals flop but if they represent those
quantities in the same way it's it's
basically absolute thanks for checking
out this clip from the tim cast irl
podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com tim
cast irl monday through friday at 8pm
where you can leave comments and super
chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to
timcast.com become a member and we even
have full bonus episodes thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all next
time